i would love to go to university and sit
on the benches to attend a class as a
regular student
distance learning is off-putting for
students
asking parents for money is hard back
home
so it's like and also like fear of
getting coveted you know when you go
outside
so there's so many things going on like
emotionally and physically had to choose
between printing a lesson and buying
food
i chose food rather than printing i'm
trying to turn to local food banks so
it'll cost me as little as possible
i'm not talking about living i'm talking
about surviving
[Music]
survival of the fittest doesn't sound
great and as you'll hear in a moment
it's not going to change anytime soon
but there are more optimistic ways of
looking at the situation for students
we'll talk to a psychologist in a moment
first this report from france
standing in line for groceries many of
the students at the paris and ontario
university are here to pick up donations
their situation is dire
rice or noodles also a student
the 24 year old volunteers to distribute
food in her area
today there's baked beans oranges and
canned goods on offer
thanks to distributing groceries i get
out and meet a few people
helping others gives me strength it
keeps me going
she also depends on food donations she's
in arrears with her rent
and lost her job at a movie theater now
she only has 170 euros
a month to live on her family can't help
her
without the assistance of eight
organizations she would be lost
normally your 20s are the best time of
your life but it's the opposite now
now she spends most of her time alone in
her 15 square meter room in front of her
computer
she has at least three online courses a
day she thought getting her master's
degree in cultural history would be very
different
this man knows the students problems but
only from a distance
math professor vassal martin corrects
papers at home on the sofa
he only meets and teaches his 120
students
virtually mentally and physically the
students are in horrible shape
and there's no real hope that it will
get better anytime soon the situation is
horrible
walking around campus is strange the
complex has over a thousand apartments
but looks like a ghost town common rooms
have been
if there are barricaded than three
people in a room security guards knock
and tell us it's not allowed
everyone is totally isolated
[Music]
today she's working for the aid
organization sos etudion
and is getting donations ready she's
always shocked that there are students
who are worse off than she is
pauline neal only has 150 euros to live
on each month
here she can get some of the bearing
necessities but only
two rolls of toilet paper
[Music]
i lost my job now i only have my stipend
getting groceries really helps otherwise
it would be a total disaster
there are so many needy students and a
few are still waiting in line for help
there's much to do
browning is an environmental
psychologist at clemson university in
south carolina and joins us from the us
matthew leaving school and heading to
uni learning to think
for yourself and fend for yourself and
enjoy your first real freedoms
is an amazing time of life but that's
not the case for this generation of
students is it
it's not and that's exactly what they
expected out of the college
experience is to develop a sense of
independence
and freedom in life and to learn who
they are and that is primarily through
social interaction with their peers and
they weren't able to do that this past
year
are these teens all going to grow up
differently from us do you reckon more
more dependent
less courageous introverted depressed
well this is a time of life where you
can set a trajectory for
your psychological health later in life
but the truth is we don't know we have
never seen this large-scale
impact on college students before
in recent history so we don't know what
the long-term impacts will be but we
certainly expect
this to last at least for the next few
years
that's an awful thing to hear what what
are the
psychological or what could be the
psychological
effects of that though considering just
the length of time
well so the the the primary
acute psychological impacts are anxiety
depressive symptoms
excessive obsessive-compulsive disorders
substance abuse stress obviously
and those can impact us our physical
health
stress for example will cause
inflammation in the body
and that can be a risk factor for a
whole host of
physical illnesses and diseases um
hopefully this will be an acute phase
and will continue
past uh the next few months as people
are getting
vaccinated but if it does um those
those psychological impacts can have
lasting physical
impacts on our health i guess what you'd
hope is that
these teens become a lot more innovative
perhaps than us but
what about planning a career how can you
do that at the moment when
so many companies are firing not hiring
you can't travel
yeah the career is one of the concerns
of students in addition to financial
concerns with what's going on
with their family who might be
supporting them going to college here in
the united states for example
it costs tens of thousands of dollars to
go
to just a basic public university much
less a private liberal arts college
and and so concerns about career are
are very strong amongst these college
students
and uh fortunately there are
some careers that are becoming uh more
readily
available uh such as pillow work and
i would expect that more and more
college students will be working
remotely
both during the pandemic and afterwards
in these
blossoming career fields i know there's
also a big interest in science and
research
and health uh how could all this affect
those sectors
well it's interesting i'm an academic
and
the number of journal submissions has
increased uh almost 100 percent in some
fields
during the pandemic in other fields it
hasn't been as large but overall
the productivity of scholars has
increased at a rate we haven't seen
before in recent history
however that's largely amongst academics
researchers who are not caring for
children at home
and that's predominantly done by women
in this country although not exclusively
by any means
and so what with the impact on science
is that
it's becoming increasingly competitive
and unfortunately
some inequities in science including a
gender inequity are becoming larger
matthew one more question uh what would
your advice to
students be someone who's wanting to
start a career or start a new career
out there what would be your
encouragement for them
continue trying to get through college
and realize that
this hybrid or even entirely online
format with you know interacting with
peers and colleagues
maybe what you'll be doing after college
in your career rather than
physically going to a brick-and-mortar
store so this may be
increasingly common the new norm and so
try to develop the skill sets uh that
will make you a competitive
job applicant for that so face it and
embrace it you reckon
matthew browning from clemson university
in south carolina thank you very much
nice talking to you today matthew
mentioned
substance abuse in relation to the
psychological effects of the pandemic
that's something we'll look at on
tomorrow's show now to
derrick williams our science
correspondent has been busy fielding
your questions on all things covered
if you've got something you'd like to
ask him just post your question on our
youtube channel
why is the second dose of the vaccine
causing worse reactions than the first
dose
lots of people getting vaccinated have
reported worse side effects
after the second shot now now this is
complicated
but here's my understanding of what's
going on
because it contains substances or
information on substances that the body
has never seen before
the first dose of a two-shot vaccine
triggers
a blanket emergency response in what's
called
the innate immune system think of its
elements as kind of the immune system's
shock troops that urgent response
includes the release of inflammatory
compounds so
that can for example cause discomfort at
the injection site
after the first shot but usually not a
lot more
um that's that's partially because even
strong responses from the innate immune
system
tend to be short-lived however
it's also communicating information
about the invader the whole time
to cells and what's known as the
adaptive
immune system which is responsible for
long-term
immune memory and over the course of a
couple of weeks
those cells learn to spot the pathogen
fast
if you're exposed again which is what
the body thinks has happened
when you receive the second shot when
you get it
the trained cells start spewing out
large amounts of antiviral compounds of
their own
right away and they in turn can quickly
cause the person getting the booster
shot to feel
worse side effects like fatigue or fever
but those effects usually disappear
within
a day or two the experts say and are
actually an
outward sign that the vaccine is having
the desired effect which is to engage
both branches of the immune system and
and cement
the memory of the invader i've read a
lot of reports that the side effects
after the second dose can can really be
no fun
but not everyone gets them and at least
in those who do
they disappear pretty quickly
you